you're being a little bit modest and
saying you didn't you know invent the
horror film but on the other hand there
weren't marketing focus groups or
letters streaming into studio saying I
want to see more Edgar Allan Poe on the
screen that was your invention in your
idea could you talk a little bit about
how you first came to PO how you found a
gallon po I had read in school actually
I think wasn't even high school I think
it was junior high school in an English
class of the Fall of the House of Usher
and loved it and I asked my parents for
the complete works of Edgar Allan Poe
for Christmas they were delighted to
give it to me I could have asked for a
shotgun or something and I always wanted
to make specifically the Fall of the
House of Usher and I talked aait
American International accompanied I was
working with into doing uh sure why were
they had a policy of sending out to tend
a black-and-white films as double
features two teenage films to our
science fiction to horror and they
wanted to make make two of these and I
said let me have double the money and
was something a little under two hundred
thousand dollars and I want 15 days I
want to be in the Big Ten I'm here and I
want to shoot in color and it was the
Fall of the House of Usher so once you
made that film and and started working
with Vincent Price did it just seemed
that natural that he would be right for
the subsequent films in the in the cycle
Benson was my choice from the beginning
of writing the script he was a character
star not a handsome Robert Taylor at
that time leading man he'd always been a
star a character star he was getting a
little bit older and he portrayed a
certain intelligence with a quirky and
neurotic quality that fit Roderick Usher
said how can you talk a little bit about
the
production of the pit and the pendulum
we were talking briefly about the
special effects in the film and actually
the truth is there are no special if
there are there are no real special
effects or to match shots there's the
painting of the house at the beginning
and there's a painting later on of the
depth of the of the pit everything else
was completely natural I mentioned
earlier we built this giant pendulum
there was attached to almost as high as
here I actually almost as high as that
from the ceiling and it was to come down
and swing back and forth getting lower
and lower and lower and jhankar the
young lead was strapped to a platform
and the pendulum eventually was to cut
through his shirt and cut through just
lightly we put a little sketch up in
there that it cut it cut his chest and
John was standing next to me as the prop
men were working with this and he said
Roger do you think that thing is really
safe and I thought oh I can see a
problem possibly coming up eyes at John
it is absolutely safe I'll show you I'll
get on the platform we have to rehearse
it fully anyway we'll rehearse with me I
got under the thing it started coming
down and I thought maybe jon is right
I'm not so certain but I survived and
John survived well you always talk about
the the success of your films and I
think sometimes you mean how successful
they are at the box office but but you
also talk about their success
artistically how does the pit and
pendulum figure in your estimation in
terms of as a success it rips into
really the way I would describe motion
pictures I think motion pictures are the
true that you conclude television any
concept of the moving image I think
they're the true modern art form
partially because they are for the first
time an art form of the movement but
also because they are an art and a
business
what is difficult is to try to combine
it I wasn't tryin my self as working as
an artist I thought of working as a
craftsman I'll do the best I can as a
craftsman if occasionally something
approaches the level of art that's great
but I want to work as a craftsman and
out of the pit and the pendulum is an
example of that of taking a subject that
is maybe not fully commercial because
there were certain elements of Poe that
he himself of course was a great writer
and a great artist and that possibly
elevated to a high level of craft